It's called a teratoma....and it's literally
the most terrifying thing I've ever heard
about in my life.
Hello hello everyone, Laci Green here for
DNews.
When you think of places where you might find
TEETH growing, I bet your...brain...doesn't
come to mind.
But that's exactly what happened last week
in Maryland in the body of a 4 month old infant.
The baby had a brain tumor, and when doctors
went to remove it, they found several fully
formed teeth in there, similar to the teeth
normally found in the lower jaw.
The baby is now in recovery.
It's a WTF moment that is currently making
my whole week.
Nature is a beautiful freak, yall.
Why --or how-- on earth were there teeth growing
in his brain?
While the exact causes are unknown, scientists
have hypothesized that the reason teeth might
grow in a tumor is because the tumors themselves
develop from the same cells that create teeth.
This case is a particularly ~strange~ occurrence
because teeth have never been found in a craniopharyngioma,
which is the rare brain tumor the infant had.
However, this isn't the first time doctors
have found teeth growing in strange places....
Take the bizarre case of Miguel Belcon, who
had always had breathing troubles growing
up that were blamed on his heavy weight.
When he was 18, he began coughing up blood,
leading scientists to find a basketball sized
tumor in his chest, which was growing not
only teeth, but hair, and what may have been
the beginnings of fetal eyes.
He lost nearly 30 pounds from the surgery
and is now doing a-OK.
Another 23 year old woman in India was born
with an abnormal left eye, which continued
to swell throughout her youth.
Finally, desperate and losing her vision,
she went to the doctors and found out that
she had a tumor in her eye which had grown
2 fully formed teeth.
While it's EXTREMELY rare, she was not the
first to have teeth growing in her eyes -- there
have been 70 cases documented since 1850.
The types of tumor in question with these
cases were teratoma tumors, which, unlike
a craniopharyngioma, contain all 3 types of
tissue that are found in human embryos.
They're an aggressive (but usually benign)
type of tumor that can pop up all over the
body -- like the brain, lungs, or liver.
But what about....the vagina?
Yes, I am referring to so-called "vagina dentata"".
Is there some truth in there?
This 21st century folklore has endured all
the way from Ancient Greek mythology.
The story goes that women's bodies have secret
abilities that are quite dangerous - and having
sex with her could result in male castration.
If there was ever a story that summed up the
enduring fear of female sexuality throughout
history, this is the one.
Although.....teeth HAVE been found growing
in ~ovaries~ so.... better be on the lookout
just in case ;)
Thanks for joining me for DNews everyone,
don't forget to subscribe because we'll be
back soon with more science updates!